PRESENTER: I wanted to welcome
you all to another outstanding
Authors at Google Talk.
I can only do very little in
terms of introduction here.
The true expert is fellow
Googler Stephanie McClellan.
But she did give me a few
pointers as we introduce our
latest speaker today.
Michael Romano is here speaking
about his book, which
is called "The Family Table."
It's a story of chef and staff
meals at the Union Square Cafe,
which is where he is the
culinary director.
And this James Beard-winning,
massively awesome restaurant,
massively awesome staff, really
takes the concept of
enlightened hospitality
to heart.
And so that's truly apparent in
the staff meal, which is in
essence what you feed
the folks that are
on staff for you.
Very similar to how we approach
life at Google.
And so we will have some time
for questions at the end.
And for now, please join me in
welcoming Michael to Google.
Thank you very much.
MICHAEL ROMANO: Hi.
Thank you for coming.
Very excited to be here.
Great to see Stephanie
up on the screen.
So I don't know, it's a little
embarrassing, coming here to
talk to you about staff meal,
because you have the most
amazing facility here.
I just got a tour.
I just had a wonderful lunch
at Long Life, was it?
Long Life Cafe?
And I'm very jealous.
You have the most incredible
food facility I've ever seen.
I was at the New York Google
office, and that was pretty
spectacular.
But this is amazing.
Very excited about
our new book.
This is my third cookbook.
The first two are "The Union
Square Cafe Cookbook," and the
second one was called "Second
Helpings from Union Square
Cafe." Kind of turned out to be
a bad name, because people
thought it was a book about
leftovers, but it's not.
And they've done very well.
But this one is very exciting.
I don't know if any of you are
authors, or have written a
book or anything.
But you work very hard at
it, sometimes for years.
And then it gets processed and
put together and published.
And the moment when they put it
in your hands is a really
amazing moment.
It's like welcoming a newborn
into the world.
And it's just very exciting.
Because you never know.
You never know really what it's
going to look like until
there it is, in your hand.
So the idea for this book,
"Family Table," is that every
day in our restaurant, twice
a day, the staff-- which is
always referred to as
family, by the way.
The cooks don't say, I'm
making staff meal.
They always say, who is
making family today?
It's just a tradition
in our business.
And every day, they sit down to
a meal at lunch and dinner.
So we thought that in itself
would be an interesting topic
for a book.
What is the food that is being
prepared for these people?
And it's not the food that we
are preparing for you, the
guests who come to
our restaurants.
Quite different.
And then there was another
thought that entered into
this, which really convinced
us that we
should do this book.
And I say we-- this is my
co-author, Karen Stabiner--
was all the stories about the
folks who work in our
restaurant.
So we have over 2000 employees,
which I know here
seems like nothing.
But for us it's pretty
amazing.
And so all the people--
and some of them have been with
us for over 20 years,
because our oldest restaurant,
the Union Square Cafe, where I
started as executive chef.
Is going to be 28 years
old this October.
So we have people who've
been with us for
a really long time.
And what happens, of course,
is they develop a kind of a
connection to the place that
goes beyond if you're there
for a year or two.
They're connected to the
history of the place.
They carry it around with them,
and they teach this.
They are the keepers of the
history and the everything
that goes into making
our places.
And they teach this to the young
people coming in, the
new people coming into
our restaurants.
So we thought, well, that also
would be an interesting topic
to put together in a book
along with the recipes.
So that's essentially
what we've done.
We've got great recipes, and
we've got great stories about
the folks who populate
our restaurants,
and make them alive.
They bring the spirit, the
soul to the restaurants.
And without that, a restaurant
is not really terribly
interesting.
It won't ever be great if it
doesn't have that soul.
So what's interesting about the
recipes, I think, is that
you have these cooks, right?
And has anyone here ever
worked in a restaurant?
Ah, see that?
There's a few.
The cook will be assigned
to do family.
And he or she will have
certain parameters.
They'll be very pressed
for time.
That's always a given.
Because they have their
own work to do.
It's not like it's a dedicated
cafeteria, where they're just
doing food for staff.
They have to do their
other work as well.
So they'll have very
limited time.
They'll have definite parameters
as to what they're
going to use for the food.
We don't want to ever see
truffles going out to the
dining room for the staff,
and things like that.
So they have to make quick
decisions, work quickly, and
come up with tasty
food in a hurry.
And I find that has a tremendous
synergy with
someone cooking at home for a
family, because you probably
face the same kinds
of constraints.
The parameters are
about the same.
So we hope that that is going
to be an enticement to folks
cooking at home.
Because they'll see recipes here
that can be done pretty
quickly, they're very tasty,
and not going to tax your
pocketbook too much.
But you're going to enjoyed
them, and they're going to
broaden your repertoire
of things that
you can cook at home.
The other thing is something
that I hadn't really planned
on when we started the book.
Was the racial ethnicity
across this
book is pretty amazing.
Because the cooks are cooking
wherever they've come from--
they're Dominican, or
Mexican, or Asian.
They bring this to the
food that they know
and love to the table.
And so we have a great diversity
in the book of
different recipes and different
flavors, which I
think is really a lot of fun.
I'm also hoping something
for this book.
This is a little deeper,
a little bit
of a long term hope.
But I know that's out there,
certainly in the television
world, there's a kind of a
notion that persists, I guess
because it makes good
television, that restaurants
are places where there's a lot
of screaming going on, and
people are really getting
emotionally
beat up and put down.
That kind of persists throughout
our industry.
And I'm hoping that this book
will just make a little dent
in that perception.
Because it shows how well
people can be treated.
We don't do all that
stuff, and I never
did that as a chef.
So I want people to see a
different side of the
restaurant business.
People have asked me, why is
staff meal, why is family
table so important?
And I tell them for
two reasons.
One is physiological.
Meaning that you need
to be nourished.
If you're working in a kitchen
or dining room,
it's difficult work.
It's challenging work.
You're on your feet
for a long hours.
And if you're in the dining
room, you're facing guests,
and you always have to bring
a level of hospitality, of
upbeat energy to it.
So if you're not fed, and you're
thinking about how
hungry you are, and you're
around all this food, and
you're serving this food, you're
going to be distracted.
And you're going to be serving
someone their chicken, and
you're going to be thinking,
I wish I had a
piece of that chicken.
I want to take a little piece
right off of that
plate and eat it.
And your mind is going to be
not focused so much on what
you're supposed to be doing.
And at the most basic level, you
need the energy to be able
to carry on and do the job.
So that's number one.
Number two is the psychological
aspect to it,
which is cooking good food
and serving good food--
and again, you folks know
this very well here--
is a way of taking
care of people.
And when you take care of people
in that way, people
feel taken care of.
And they appreciate it, and they
have a reciprocal kind of
experience, where they feel good
about the place they're
working in.
And this is a great
example of it.
So the folks in our restaurants,
if they're well
taken care of that way, they're
fed, and also they
feel, this place
cares about me.
They care enough
to serve food.
I know at one of our
restaurants, Gramercy Tavern--
that was our second one
to open, in 1994--
I'm always amazed at how
carefully the food that goes
out for family is labeled with
a lot of details about what's
in the food.
So that someone who doesn't want
to eat pork, or doesn't
want to eat gluten, or
things like that will
know ahead of time.
And believe me, that
is not the norm in
the restaurant business.
Often in the restaurant
business, it's if you get a
meal, it's like, here it is.
And if you don't like it, too
bad, and you can just go out
and fend for yourself.
So I'm really happy and
proud to see that
kind of thing go on.
And Gramercy was a big
contributor in this book, and
they did it really, really
joyfully and willingly, and
they were very proud
of the book itself.
That was really a great
aspect to it.
I noticed after the book came
out, and I showed it around to
people who contributed the
recipes, they were very proud
and they were just delighted.
And they couldn't wait to get
a copy and take it home and
show their families that
they were in this book.
And there's many pictures
of the staff.
And they were proud that they
had contributed to the book.
From my perspective--
I mentioned before that I have
already done two cookbooks--
a big challenge of this book,
which made it, in a way, the
most difficult work I've done,
was that in my first two
books, the Union Square Cafe
books, the recipes that you
find in there are my recipes
that I mostly created myself
and was cooking at
the restaurant.
So they were road-tested,
so to speak.
They were broken in, we knew
people liked them.
So really, the challenge for the
book was just to get them
from restaurant quantities and
restaurant technique to work
well for the home cook.
And that's not all
that difficult.
So it was an exercise in
transcribing these recipes for
the home cook.
This book, these are
not my recipes.
These are the recipes that the
cooks in our restaurants put
together every day
for the family.
So the job became getting with
them, trying not to upset
their routine and their schedule
too much, but trying
to extract from them what
it was they were making.
And believe me, they were
not using recipes.
They were not putting
a teaspoon of this,
and a cup of that.
They were just throwing stuff
together, literally, and
coming up with some
good-tasting food.
But, as we say, on the fly.
So Karen Stabiner, my co-author,
did a lot of the
legwork of getting in there and
trying to pull out from
the cooks what it is
they were doing.
And believe me, they were
sometimes wildly inaccurate.
A cook might say, yeah, I put
about a cup of that in there.
And really it was
a tablespoon.
So then, when I got the first
draft raw recipe handed to me
and set about testing them in
the kitchen, because we want
to make sure that they work, I
was getting some wild results.
Oh, this is not going to work.
It just wasn't right.
And I knew what had been
served was good.
So I had to bridge that gap
between what had been served,
and what I saw on the page, and
make them come together.
And sometimes I exercised a
little bit of executive
privilege and tweaked it here
and there, so that I knew that
this was going to be
a good recipe.
Sometimes I thought,
well, this needs a
little bit of this.
So I didn't hesitate to add it,
because it's all in the
spirit of "The Family Table."
I'm proud of the recipes, and
I think they came out well,
and I think you're going
to enjoy them.
How many of you actually
cook at home?
Oh, almost everybody.
That's great.
I got the right audience
here, this is good.
So I'm going to tell you in
a very un-objective, very
subjective way, my favorite
recipe-- because I get asked
that a lot in the book--
is my mother's lasagna.
Now, you wonder why my mother's
lasagna is in this
book, because it's not something
we might serve to
the family in our restaurants.
There's a category of
recipes in here that
came from the chefs.
Now, the chefs in restaurants
don't cook family meal.
They're busy doing other things,
and they assign it to
the cooks, the line cooks.
So we thought, well, we'd like
to include them in there,
because they probably have some
really great recipes.
So we asked the chefs to
contribute recipes that they
might cook at home for their
families, or had been cooked
for them when they were growing
up by their family.
And that's how we got these
group of recipes in here, and
that's how my mother's lasagna
wound up in here.
Because that's, for
me, the number
one memory of childhood.
It was always a very special
time when she made it.
She didn't make it that
often, because it's a
fair amount of work.
But when she did, my sister and
I were always delighted,
and it was always
so wonderful.
And so I had to go back
and research, and
find how she did it.
What ingredients and what
proportion she used.
My brother-in-law helped a
lot, because he's a great
cook, and he used to
watch my mother.
She's no longer alive.
But thank god, he noted down
what she used to do.
So we pieced it together, and
it came out really well.
And if you make it, I promise
you're going to enjoy it.
And one of the things she
did was to make--
her meatballs were
really wonderful.
So she would make the meatballs,
cook the meatballs
in the sauce, and then actually
slice them and lay
them out, shingled, as the meat
layer in the lasagna.
So instead of just having a
sloppy joe kind of ground meat
in there, these were seasoned,
held together, beautiful.
And they're very tender,
you'll see if
you make the recipe.
They're intentionally
very soft.
So that when you eat it in the
lasagna, it's just this whole
sort of amalgam of--
and then the cheese layer is
really wonderful, so it all
works together.
We had a book party for press
in New York just before the
book came out, and that was one
of the dishes I served.
And nobody wanted to leave
until was all gone.
And I got a lot of great
comments, which is very
gratifying.
And there's a number of other
recipes that I really love.
There's one called
Dominican Beef.
So-called because the fellow who
makes it, Viktor, is from
the Dominican Republic.
And he started as a porter--
that is to say, would be
receiving deliveries, and
keeping the basement in order.
And then he graduated
to a prep cook.
And occasionally, he would make
this wonderful beef stew,
essentially.
It was very simple.
It was a handful
of ingredients.
But it's so delicious.
Some magic happens
when he makes it.
And I would always look
forward to the days
when he made that.
And now, the current chef at
Union Square Cafe, Carmen
Quagliata, actually put the
dish on the brunch menu.
So there's an example
of a dish that did
make it to the guest.
And we're very proud of it.
And Viktor is just overjoyed
with having his recipe not
only in the book, but
on the menu as well.
And the photography is a fellow
named Marcus Nilsson.
I think he's from Finland.
Very interesting guy.
Did some wonderful
photography.
It's a little edgy.
A lot of them have
black background.
And I love the way
things came out.
Everything is very unstaged, in
a way, especially the shots
of the people who
made the food.
I hope that you can get a
sense of the people's
personality through the profiles
that are written in
the book, and then see through
the food that they contributed
a little bit of that personality
come through.
Because it's for me is
really clear, because
I know these people.
It's a fun part of the book.
I have long, long memories of
staff meals, family meals,
back to the '70s, when I was
working in Europe, and France,
and Switzerland, where I first
saw this institution of the
staff sitting down.
Although in France, and in
Switzerland as well, we never
ate together with
the dining room.
The kitchen ate separately
from the dining room.
And that was something
I wasn't too fond of.
And when I came to Union Square
Cafe in 1988, I wanted
everybody to eat together.
And that's what we still do.
In the main dining room,
everyone sits.
The cooks will will sit together
with other cooks
because they want to talk about
things, and the servers
will sit with themselves.
And in Union Square Cafe in
particular, there are the
staff members--
that being the oldest
of our restaurants--
who have been there for such a
long time that they have their
seats, and that's where they
sit for family meal.
And the new person is quickly
informed, you don't sit there.
That's so-and-so's seat.
But in a very benign way.
It's just people get
very comfortable.
Again, it feels like their home,
because they're made to
feel so comfortable
and taken care of.
Which is, again, clearly
something that's going on here
in an amazing way.
You have so many things here
that can help you get things
done that you need
to get done.
I'm seeing laundry rooms, I'm
seeing all kinds of--
it's astounding.
So you understand that concept
very well, and taken it to a
much greater degree.
But our family table is our
attempt at doing that.
I was talking to my partner,
Danny Meyer, before leaving on
the book tour.
And he said, maybe there are
always certain criteria.
And they kind of change, they're
kind of topical.
Criteria by which people
judge, or prejudge, a
restaurant from what they've
heard about.
These days it would be, do they
practice sustainable cooking?
Is it organic cooking?
Is its farm-to-table?
Is it seasonal?
These kinds of parameters.
And he said, maybe just maybe
people will start to think
about, hmm, I wonder how they
treat their staff, in terms of
the staff meal?
Because by and large, people
don't think about that when
they go to a restaurant.
What does the staff eat?
I don't know if it occurs
to them that the
staff eats as well.
And that's part of a bigger
picture, I think, of the
question of, how well is
the staff treated?
Because I go back to the days in
Europe, and I won't mention
names or places, but it was
not always the rule.
We were treated kind
of harshly.
It was not uncommon, in the
kitchen for example,
certainly, to be screamed
at, and to be even hit,
physically, or have things
thrown at you and whatnot.
And the dining room also was
kept on a very short
leash, so to speak.
And then you're expected to turn
around and be genuinely
kind and hospitable to the
guests, which I always find to
be a very difficult maneuver.
Because it seems to me--
and again, this is why it kind
of bothers me to see this
prolonging of this idea of the
chef as screamer, someone who
just wants to vent on the staff
and belittle people.
Picture if you're in a
restaurant, you're a guest in
a restaurant, and you are
looking at the menu.
And you see something you
like, but you don't
necessarily want it the way
it's written on the menu.
I'd like this, the roast
chicken, but could I get it
with the garnish that's
with the steak here?
And so you're going to ask
your server, right?
So imagine two scenarios.
If your server knows that when
he or she goes back into the
kitchen and asks the chef, she's
going to get her head
chopped off.
She's going to get screamed
at and really get
hassled from the shelf.
How is she going to react to
you, with your request?
Some part of her is going to
cringe, and be saying, I wish
you hadn't asked me that.
But on the other hand,
the other scenario.
If the chef is also genuinely
hospitable and kind, and says,
sure, we'll make that work.
No problem.
She's going to have, or he's
going to have, a much more
open spirit, and be much more
accessible to you as the
guest, and give you better
hospitality.
And one of the most wonderful
things I've ever heard my
partner Danny say, Danny
Meyers, describing the
difference between service
and hospitality.
He says, service
is a technique.
It's a one-way street.
It happens to you,
as the guest.
How well your plate is
presented, how well your plate
is cleared away, how well the
wine is poured, have you got
the right cutlery.
That's the service.
Hospitality is a dialogue.
It has to happen between you and
what you want and what you
need, and the server, who has to
be listening so that he or
she understands what you
as a guest need.
We have an idea how we're
going to present
our product to you.
But you are going to have ways
that you want to modify that.
Either subtle ways, or
not-so-subtle ways.
And we have to be open to
hearing that, and engaging
you, and finding a way
to make that happen.
And then you're going
to be happy.
You're going to be
comfortable.
I think here, what I see
around here, is a real
dialogue of what do you need, in
terms of you being in this
workplace, to be productive,
to be happy--
and therefore more productive?
And there's a lot of effort made
to provide that for you.
So it's the same.
It's the same kind of
hospitality that
we're talking about.
AUDIENCE: It's just an
interesting idea to think of
all the chefs at some of these
really amazing restaurants
just sitting around
having dinner.
And I'd be terrified to
cook for them all.
Is there a hands-off policy,
you're not allowed to critique
family dinner?
MICHAEL ROMANO: No!
AUDIENCE: When they serve it, is
it kind of like, all hands
on deck critiquing it?
I just would be terrified
to serve.
You're talking about, they have
a little bit of time,
they're not as experienced
as the other chefs.
I would think that that would
be kind of a terrifying
experience.
MICHAEL ROMANO: It could be
for a new person, maybe.
But I think it's an opportunity
for that person to
step up and show what
they can do.
Because this is not
something--
The chef has a menu.
And the cooks prepare the menu
according to the chefs wishes
of how it should be done.
So there's not too much
room for personal
interpretation there.
Sometimes you'll get in trouble
if you do that.
But for cooking family meal, you
do have room to interpret.
So it's a chance for
you to speak.
If you're a timid person, then
yeah, you might be a little
nervous about it.
As far as feedback, people
will give feedback.
Hopefully in a kind way, and
not a destructive way.
And it's not about, oh, I
thought this needed a little
bit more salt, or you
should've put
a little bit more--
No.
Basically, what I've seen over
the years, is feedback when
people feel they're not getting
enough of a certain
type of nourishment, or it's
getting too monotonous, we're
having the same thing
every day, or
there's not enough variety.
That's a big one.
That's really a big one.
If it's hot dogs and sauerkraut
every day for a
week, you're going to have
problems, and people are going
to speak up about it.
It's an opportunity for a cook
to show that he or she is
genuinely interested and
cares about cooking.
Because I have a great deal of
concern and skepticism about a
cook who's saying to me, yeah,
I love to cook, I want to
learn, I want to be great,
and then makes a
miserable family meal.
Food is food.
If you're trying your best to
do my menu and cook those
dishes, but when it comes to
doing family you just put out
anything, that shows something
about you.
It tells me something about you
and your level of caring,
which is a big concern.
So it's a good way to assess.
And then on the other end of
the spectrum, you see cooks
who really put their heart and
soul into it, and they want
family to be great, and they
love the positive feedback
that comes to them
from the staff.
Like, great meal!
That was so good!
That kind of thing.
But thanks, that's
a good question.
AUDIENCE: Thanks so
much for coming.
MICHAEL ROMANO: Oh,
my pleasure.
AUDIENCE: I've actually had
the pleasure of going to a
number of your restaurants,
which are great.
And I know that they all have
very different personalities.
So I'm wondering a little bit
about the difference in the
atmosphere and the setup of
family meal between the
restaurants.
And then the second question is,
I know your staff may move
between restaurants.
So as they move, have you seen
favorite family meal dishes
move from restaurant
to restaurant?
MICHAEL ROMANO: Yeah.
So the first question.
Definitely the way the meal
is set up and the way it's
served, or the way people eat,
is very much in line with the
feeling of the restaurant.
From very casual, like our
barbecue restaurant, Blue
Smoke, to--
One of the restaurants that's
included in the list, and
there are recipes from it,
is 11 Madison Park, which
actually is no longer
our restaurant.
The chef and GM, who are two
incredibly talented guys,
decided they wanted to buy
the restaurant from
us, and they did.
And so they're off on
their own doing it.
But at the time that we started
writing this book, it
was part of the family.
And that was a little bit
more formal, and the
meal reflected that.
And both the food that was
cooked in the way it was
presented, you could
see the difference.
You could definitely
And for me, it's fun because I
can get to go to any of the
family meals that I
want, and get that
feeling from each one.
Now for cooks--
yes, you're right.
Cooks do migrate, I like to call
it, from one restaurant
to another.
If they happen to be the cook
that gets on the line and
makes family, I'm sure they're
going to bring stuff from one
to the other, although
I don't have
concrete examples of that.
And they'll get to see what
one family meal is like as
opposed to another.
There are differences,
I have to say.
Stylistically, and also I keep
coming back in my mind to
Gramercy Tavern, which seems,
almost every day, to serve an
outstanding variety, and a
tremendous amount of care goes
into the meal.
It's an interesting experience
to visit a few of them and see
the differences.
And thank you all very much
for your attention.